[Music]
on TV on Radio and on your smartphone
this is talk TV
[Music]
it's another person a British army
colonel was forced out of the military
for agreeing that men can't become women
he joins me live Bradley Cooper faced a
massive backlash for wearing a false
nose and playing a Jewish character in
his new movie should star roles be
reserved for actors who actually lead
the lives of their characters or is it
just acting I'll talk to Rupa Everett
plus Rockstar psychologist Stephen
Pinker made his name by saying the world
has never been in a better place after a
global pandemic economic collapse and a
raging war in Europe does he still
believe that he'll join me live too
[Music]
live from the news building in London
this is Piers Morgan uncensored well
good evening of London welcome to Piers
Morgan and sensor when I launched this
show I promised to cancel our Insidious
cancel Culture The Usual Suspects
sneered Castle culture is fake they said
there's nothing whatsoever to do with
the real world it's a populist argument
I see and hear it every day canceled
culture is not real so Time Magazine CNN
thinks it's time to cancel this talk of
canceled culture the new Statesman rafts
that canceled culture does not exist but
it does exist apart for anything else I
wouldn't be doing this show if Castle
culture didn't exist it's everywhere
it's the creeping fear now stalking all
of us that we're only wherever one
mistake away or a perceived mistake away
from a scandal that can end your career
acting Niger River is coming up later
from the show early today he described
did perfectly
nowadays I'm absolutely terrified every
time I have to do an interview I come
out in hives and I never ever dare read
them because it's so scary you know you
can't really you have to be so careful
what you say
um you can't really uh just chat and and
have a lively discussion with someone
you always have to watch what you're
saying and I find that very uh it's very
alien to me because I've spent my life
really I'm having a lovely time with
journalists and chatting about
everything and now that's that's uh
that's a little more complicated
frankly the society has taken this turn
and it's no longer just celebrities or
public figures you need to be afraid
take Colonel Kelvin Wright who's a bit
of a British hero as a reservist army
medic he ran the emergency department at
Camp Bastion in Afghanistan he flew in
Chinook helicopters across Enemy Lines
to rescue soldiers and civilians
suffering the gruesome injuries of War
he saved many many lives over 14 years
of service but then Colonel Kelvin got
canceled full start of the British army
his crime it was to share a social media
post by a woman's rights campaigner
called Helen Joyce and all it said was
if women cannot stand in a public place
and say men cannot be women then we do
not have women's rights at all you might
agree with that statement you might not
agree with it but last time I checked in
a Democratic Society you're entitled to
your opinion
and regardless it wasn't his comment in
the first place he just shared it
but a formal complaint was of course
made LGBT activists dragged a colonel
into a disciplinary process a seven page
letter signed by these activists that is
supposedly anti-trans views he hadn't
expressed any anti-trans views had no
place in the military
so he walked away
the biggest misunderstanding about
cancer culture is it has to involve a
celebrity being expunged from public
life and there are many examples of that
happening but the reality is we're now
so used to righteous mobs throwing
Tantrums about other people's opinions
that every everybody is at risk
employers are so afraid of being shamed
for being on the wrong side of a tribal
argument they'll gladly hang you out to
dry sooner than take any risk with the
damage already done has been revealed
between the colonel Kelvin Wright has
now been cleared of any wrongdoing by an
official inquiry but his army career is
over forced out by virtue signaling busy
bodies with nothing better to do and
certainly people who never did what he
did in a war zone serving his country
it's a disgrace
what I'm joined Now by Colonel Dr Kelvin
Wright well great to have you Colonel I
I really you know I come from a family
with lots of military my brother retired
as a colonel after 37 years recently and
when I mentioned your story to him and
told him what you've done in Afghanistan
he said that was pretty hardcore Duty
flying in on those helicopters to go and
rescue people who've been severely
wounded so thank you first of all for
your service to your country I don't
know how many times you've been told
that in recent months but it's expect
not enough right interest enough in
recent months quite a few times I mean I
I joined at the height of Afghanistan my
my mission was to go and practice
medicine in a war zone I felt as a
consultant in a background of emergency
medicine and intensive care I had
something to offer and I was working in
hospital at the time where a lot of my
trainees were military and I felt it was
time for me to do my bit so it was it's
one of the proudest times and there's no
way that I'm going to let these events
overshadow what I say is the proudest
medicine I've probably ever done in my
time the most inexplicable part of your
story is not that a bunch of lgbtq 2
plus name just longer by the minute
um that these activists tried to cancel
you over reposting a quote which many
would agree with certainly from a
biological sex point of view
the most scandalous part of this is that
the Army went along with this launched a
formal investigation into you you know
told you it was specifically about the
fact you'd shared this post this other
person's opinion you had shared it that
seems to me extraordinary that the
British army would do this to somebody
like you well I mean there's two
interesting points that you you allude
to there actually the first is of course
yesterday happened
um and when this first started and I'm I
am so grateful to the help that I've had
from the Free Speech Union
um at a really trying time
um the the advice from them and having
someone on the end of a phone you can
just say actually you're okay that's
what you should be doing was phenomenal
but this process I I said the early
stages it makes you wonder who is
running the Army is it the chief of the
general staff or is it Stonewall this
this gender ideology and this fear of um
just common debate amongst professionals
is absolute be drowning out our major
institutions I mean the irony is that
people like you have served their
country to safeguard free speech and
freedoms well I agree I mean every year
so I've been a combining officer as a
great privilege for the last five years
um two is a half kernel and three is a
full kernel and um every year as a
commanding officer we would stand in
front of our troops and we would talk
about the values and standards of the
army moral courage those people moral
courage doing the right thing even when
sometimes it's difficult around you and
that's what really gets me a little bit
on this why did someone else hire up the
chain not have the moral courage to say
actually most of this complaint is
absolutely vexatious the person
complained that two or three years ago I
wouldn't let them wear their pronouns on
their uniform the Army has a uniform
policy that's not me there's a uniform
policy they complained that two years
ago my wife who'd actually come to do
casualty makeup for us at an exercise
stated she liked to see a man and a
woman dancing on Strictly Come Dancing
in the ballroom section and apparently
that shows poor family values on my part
and then there was this complaint and
those three elements the key parts of of
the complaint and then there was this
quote um which I I so it was actually
even more ridiculous than we realized it
was absolutely laughable and the fact
that no one had the moral courage to say
you know Moses is rubbish they should
not get to um a full colonally being
investigated it should not get to
someone being driven out someone fearing
for their civilian occupation because
this is the problem this kind of stuff
overreaches into others what was the
typical point for you when you said I'm
done with this uh
literally very early on um I received a
phone call and I remember the words
exactly it was you're in a lot of
trouble
this has gone all the way to the top
um the complainant is very well
connected in the diversity Network
and from that minute I just felt there
was no chance of getting a fair hearing
you you just think actually and you're
going to be investigating but within
that process I was never alone what were
you being investigated really for I
don't know so that's the interesting
point I was never shown the complaint
until after the verdict was in so I had
to make a statement on a complaint of
which I had never even seen which is
ridiculous so this seven pages the first
I saw this seven pages was after the
process was over did the seven pages
make any record of your wall record no I
mean no it was the three key points I've
talked about already and there was just
other it was people just throwing mud
hoping something with or one person
throwing mud hoping something would are
you are you transphobic do you have a
problem with transgender people not at
all
um I mean as a doctor I just treat
everyone as I find them and and as they
treat me as a human being I treat
everyone as they treat me
um as a commanding officer I'm more
interested in someone's professional
skills my patients have never said to me
excuse me are you LGBT no uh doctor
they're just one are you a doctor are
you good at your job and that's all I'm
interested absolutely not is society
just going slightly mad with this gender
ideology stuff it does feel that way I
mean when we we've lost the concept of
Reason debate we've lost the concept as
you said the Army stands for free speech
and and the fact that many men and women
over the years have paid a really high
price for the privilege of someone's
having uh the right to to speak yes and
now we are trampling all over that so
yes I do think Society is going
absolutely crazy you had to leave a job
that you loved and you've gone back to
the NHS you're now working in another
hospital in Mansfield and
Nottinghamshire
um how do you feel that your army career
was brought to an end like this
well as I said I'm just chatting I I'm
not going to let these events sell what
I thought were 14 really fabulous years
I met so many really good soldiers
Sailors air crew during my time
um I taught on trauma courses it was an
absolute privilege to do that with uh
with the with young soldiers
particularly
um it was a privilege to serve and treat
those patients when they're having a
really bad day so there's no way I'm
going to let this spoil all of that good
stuff but it does leave a rather sour
taste that after 14 years honorable
service it's brought to a rather
premature end in the in the the finding
which includes you any wrongdoing the
final report said that your Facebook
post was clearly not unlawful or duh
although some would find it disagreeable
and now when I read that I was like well
maybe they would but so what well so
what in a Democratic Society I find lots
of things disagreeable I don't want
people to lose their jobs over it
absolutely and in a Democratic Society
we have the right to have two people
having a heated debate but at the end of
the day those opinions can can be held
but for me the crucial thing and one of
the things I'm really Keen to this kind
of conversation is a precedent has been
set now the Army has been forced to say
actually we do have a responsibility on
the public sector quality Duty the force
data ruling uh is interpreted legally
it's not interpreted how the gender
Champions might like it interpreted it's
written down in law how it's interpreted
and we've got that established so future
younger soldiers Sailors air crew and
there are multiple cases of this already
going on the Free Speech Union we've got
other cases of service Personnel who
fall into this trap as well a precedent
has been set which hopefully will
protect some of them in the future
Colonel thank you very much indeed for
coming in uh you're a war hero you're a
British hero what happened to you is a
total disgrace and I'm extremely glad
you've now been uh cleared of any
wrongdoing you should never have been
being taken through this process and the
Army's loss is the nhs's gain and I wish
you all the very best for the future
thank you it's been an absolute pleasure
thank you for having me
what a story what a disgrace how has our
country come to this I mean seriously
when I says the next Rupert Everett on
his former movie co-star Russell Brand
and a lot more including cancel culture
what does he make of it don't go away
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
thank you foreign
actor to face a major backlash for
playing a character who doesn't share
his real world credentials he's starring
in a biopic of the composer Leonard
Bernstein who was gay and Jewish well
Cooper's neither of those things and
critics say is culturally offensive he
was also criticized for wearing a
prosthetic nose to look more like his
subject apparently an example of
so-called Jew phase or Bernstein's
family say he'd have no problem with it
Brian cranston's previously been slammed
for playing a disabled character despite
not being disabled Eddie Redmayne had to
apologize for playing a trans character
despite not being trans and the list
goes on and on Michael Sheen joined in
the fury by insisting only Welsh actors
can play World roles business the entire
point of acting that you play something
you're not a little early I spoke to the
great Rupert Everett about always some
more
great to see you great to see you
although it's quite ghostly because I
can't see you how are you you're looking
a little like Michael Corleone in uh
Godfather 2 with that backdrop well I'm
I'm covered in wigs you might not
believe this but I'm actually wearing
two wigs at the moment really
I read an interview you did with the
times this week that made me laugh out
loud so many times I ordered the team to
book you as a matter of urgency my first
question is when you read back
interviews like that do you chuckle like
the rest of us are you slightly
horrified at the stuff you come out with
are you proud of it how do you feel
um well I think nowadays I'm absolutely
terrified every time I have to do an
interview I come out in hives and I
never ever dare read them because it's
so scary you know you can't really you
have to be so careful what you say
um you can't really uh just chat and and
have a lively discussion with someone
you always have to watch what you're
saying and I find that very uh it's very
alien to me because I've spent my life
really I'm having a lovely time with
journalists and chatting about
everything and now that's that's uh
that's a little more complicated it is
and it's a great tragedy that's why I
did this show actually called uncensored
you can say what the hell do you like
um Talking and saying what the hell you
like it is a tragedy well yeah I did
notice at the end I did uh Everett's
best put Downs as a little breakout and
and I I appear in your best ever put
Downs are you called Madonna an old
whiny bar maid you said Michael Jackson
looked like a character from Shrek and
Piers Morgan was hung like a budgie
we've been through this beautiful again
I've admitted you had no evidence for
that slur
no one needs evidence anymore not these
days exactly exactly
um let's talk about a few things in the
news because there's a lot going on
which I immediately thought of you when
I hear these stories notably uh the fury
over Bradley Cooper playing Leonard
Bernstein in the biopic Maestro the the
great uh musical impresario and now the
fiori is simply that Bradley Cooper is
not himself Jewish or gay like Bernstein
why should that be a problem why is
there a fury about this it appears I
don't know for me it's ridiculous I
think uh acting is about acting you
don't have to be Jewish to play Jewish
you don't have to be gay to play gay I
think the thing that's irritating for
gay actors is that quite often we don't
get the chance to play straight but that
doesn't mean to say that straight actors
shouldn't be playing gay I felt deeply
moved by Behind the Candelabra with Matt
Damon I felt moved by the effort and the
detail with which they attacked their
roles
um I'd love of course seeing gay actors
playing gay Parts I'd like to see more
gay arches playing straight Parts I
don't see uh that this fear that of
cultural appropriation it doesn't make
sense that's what acting is about
essentially yeah I mean I've been saying
this for for a long time now the whole
purpose of acting is to play something
you're not right so if the new rules are
that you can only play
roles which are literally you that's not
acting to me well it is acting there's
one side of acting that is like that
after all the big movie stars uh you
know of the past anyway they more or
less did play themselves but that's not
the only side of acting there's lots of
other things in acting and particularly
uh in the theater and particularly in
independent cinema you want to see
people doing different things it's
exciting it's fun you want to follow
someone's career from playing I don't
know from to Romeo or whatever
it is
um but but to say that you can only only
a gay person can play a gay person or
only a straight person can play a
straight person is wrong after all human
beings aren't essentially that different
from one another
group what was interesting to me was
Leonard Bernstein's own family came out
and said was certain our dad would have
been fine with it so there's no offense
by the people who everyone is getting
offended on behalf of in other words the
Leonard Bernstein family they don't have
a problem of this the the the the
Scandal if you like has been completely
generated in the normal way by virtue
signalers hitting social media and
saying I'm outraged
no absolutely in a very small number of
people as well most people I've talked
to have really enjoyed the movie and
loved him and I think he's an incredible
actor and it's a great shame that the
movie gets tarnished in a time when we
really need movies to to press on and do
well
I completely agree I mean it doesn't
help to me for this to be when people
like Michael Sheen the actor said he
doesn't like non-welsh actors playing
Welsh characters he finds it hard to
accept given that he himself has played
Tony Blair David Frost very successfully
but they last time I checked weren't
Welsh right well I just think you know
Everyone's entitled to their opinion
after all but I don't agree about that
myself
you touched on earlier people say or do
things and bang uh they get canceled and
so on
um you appeared in a movie uh with
Russell Brown what do you make of this
scandal in particular not necessarily
him or the allegations against him but
about the place we Now now find
ourselves in a society when allegations
get made but before due process has been
seen to be done
people get obliterated is that is that
right and proper well I think it's
there's two things to say here obviously
one one of the things we have to always
preempt this conversation with this rape
is a horrible terrible thing and we're
all against it however uh you know I
would like to quote to you the Magna
Carta which says no free man is to be
arrested or imprisoned or outlawed or
exiled or in any way ruined nor will we
go against him or send against him
except by the lawful Judgment of his
peers or by the law of the land and that
is what we should keep two peers I agree
I agree with that and I think it's
really important and it doesn't matter
what you think of Russell Brand when you
were in in uh some trillions with him I
think what were your Recollections of
him as a bloke when you were with him uh
well there were a lot of beautiful women
on Saint trinians and there was never
any uh Scandal to do with Russell Brandt
and I'm quite a tittle tattle and I've
always got my ear to the wall so I'm
pretty sure that there wasn't uh he kept
himself to himself uh he ate funny food
you know he's one of those he's a
strange character he's one of those
people who can swap heroin for bird food
you know in the flash of an eye and uh
and and I don't agree with actually more
or less anything he says and I do think
he's a character rather like Rob spear
you know who had to wait for to meet the
king for two weeks and then suddenly
became revolutionary through his own
kind of thwarted uh bitter pride and I
do feel that Russell Brand has an Envy
of wealth which is quite uh weird but
um he behaved perfectly well very well
on um
um on Saint trinians you know he
probably had to concentrate on acting
most of the time yeah
you say in the times interview another
thing which really uh struck me I come
from a Survivor generation rather than
the victim generation you know I love
that because that is really that's what
I think which is that if you go through
enough stuff in previous generations you
tend to it tends to toughen you up it
hardens you up but what what people
didn't have time for or an inclination
was to wallow in their own victimhood
but we've now moved to a place where not
only are people doing that in large
numbers but they're kind of monetizing
it they're becoming famous off the back
of it it's almost like being a victim
now something to be praised which I find
a very disconcerting way for society to
go
I I agree with you I think uh you know
in in my youth uh you know it was it was
quite a rough and tumble world and uh
you had to uh you had to be very
Vigilant and aware of what was going on
and you had to fight your corner you
know certainly in show business as uh as
the actor Edmund Keane said uh you know
theater is not made for those who bleed
easily uh you have to be tough in this
business there's no point going into it
if you're going to wilt at the first
fence and uh and I think that gives you
a resilience and that resilience uh is
is a great thing for your whole life
really I think um
to play to one's own weakness is uh is
is uh often just not
not a good good idea really because it
just makes you weaker and weaker and
weaker
you said that you were excited by the
thought of dying
explain yourself I am why would that
excite you uh I don't I think the thing
about pain and illness is is horrible of
course and and and being frightened is
always horrible but the actual idea of
death I think is um exciting and I think
what happens to you for myself I believe
that there is
an energy which is the energy that built
or constructed the big bang and I think
it's passing through all of us and I
think we are
that energy and somehow that energy
keeps moving it's very difficult for us
to grasp because we're so hung up on our
own identity of me Rupert and I will
never change my spots etc etc our
characters are very very superficial uh
parts of us they're just a kind of
carapace I think and inside that is the
space of whatever you want to call it
God or the universe or or the flow of
energy that is you know constantly
moving outwards and expanding that's
right and if you could choose the manner
of your death what would you choose
uh the manner of my death well obviously
it would be very nice uh either to die
in my sleep or for someone to like just
shoot you in the back of the head uh
while you're going to Safeways
anymore waitrose I will make myself
available as revenge for the budgie
comment
anyway listen Piers what I came on to
talk about by the way was my place
and it's uh and it's on tour yeah and
we're in bath now we're going to
Chichester uh it's a very funny Play
It's like check off but it's also like
Dad's Army it's written by John Mortimer
a great writer eloquent peers and
eloquence I think is one of the things
that's beginning to be missing yeah I
went out for tea this afternoon and the
girl at the table next to me is going
like like like like like like I mean it
just never stopped and we're letting our
language disappear and language which
we've made over two million years and it
hasn't been easy and we should cherish
it and this play does I look forward to
that and I endorse everything you just
said about language it's a bug bearer of
mine in fact we actually have a lot of
things that we agree about rubler it may
be our old Advanced age but we've
reached a place where I think we agree
with more things than we disagree
I agree I do agree with you on many
things peers it's great to have you on
Facebook thank you very much everybody
particularly on your about your wife who
I'm very fond of yeah and she's very
fond of you a little too fond for my
liking but there we are thank you very
much peers see you next time all the
better welcome anytime thank you very
much thanks a lot all the best lots of
love bye
if any old guests were like him just see
what they think
on Thursday next talking you're saying
what they think Professor Stephen Pinker
is a rock star intellectual he's famous
for expanding that the world's making
great progress does he still believe
that have we really never had it so good
he's up next
[Music]
good evening I'm Piers Morgan uncensored
in New York City King peers and King Q I
think it's only one for one king
he's mopped your weight Trump yeah look
at him fail stop working just because
their skin folk don't mean their Kinfolk
do you believe you can win this war he's
making me cry again I'm trying to force
you out yes I feel betrayed keep it
award-winning
Lucy Lefty will die behind bars and a
senior Doctor Who first raised concerns
about that he wants NHS managers to be
regulated we needed answers a lot sooner
this is what seven years down the line I
mean it's completely ludicrous we need
accountability we need performance in
all walks of life if this nurse had
misgendered somebody on a ward she'd
have been out the door when they first
got together there were press stories
weighty Katie that would make her a
better Princess of Wales Maxwell agreed
to be interviewed for the very first
time I honestly wish I'd never met him
Donald Trump has just said he expects to
be arrested at 7 30 P.M
the concelli party can certainly win the
next election yes
did you say yes I have taken drugs and
they've bent the rules or lied on the
visa application form and therefore got
it there needs to be an intervention
around abortion laws Parliament is
Sovereign Parliament can determine these
things
the rest of the world has watched on in
sort of mounting horror as this story
has unraveled for you it was incredibly
personal the death toll from the Titanic
tragedy has risen to 1522 and may God
rest your souls
let it roll
[Music]
juicing oil the knock-on effect is far
larger than just CO2 I nearly have
empathy when I'm speaking some I don't
know you're probably going to vote me
off shorts
some of them they're easily lit
you can kiss my American Air thank you
very much
very nice of you
Twitter you Sons can you please
reinstate my account thank you that's a
threat that you'd be worried about so
are you saying that you're being
overwhelmed that you're inundated we are
really working hard for you we're just
asking patients to be patient with us
you weren't asked to give evidence to
the grand jury I'm the only one that has
Battalion materials you don't drink
never taken drunk you're stinking Rich
should you be concerned
if it's on your mind it's on talk TV
it's about you and your opinions if
you're thinking about it we're talking
about it
it's all about me that's a joke
[Music]
this is talk TV
foreign
[Music]
pandemic kill Millions left many more of
us locked up and miserable for months on
end the Earth it's apparent in the
process of sizzling us all to death
through climate change Russia's invasion
of Ukraine brought War to Europe and
nudged the world closer to nuclear
Armageddon all of this while inflation
is soaring massive economies face
recession and children and stop living
with their parents until they're my age
well if you believe what you read then
this broken and battered world of ours
has ever been more racist sexist or
divided who better to put this into
proper context though than my next
Professor Stephen Pinker who coined the
term
progressophobia Professor great to see
you
thank you I've wanted to have you in
this program for a long time because I
actually quoted from you from your
brilliant book Enlightenment now uh in
my own book uh called wake up last year
and it was like a Clarion call to the
world to wake up and one of the reasons
was as you rightly observed actually all
things considered there's ever been a
better time to be alive now do you still
believe that today
well I don't know about uh this very
moment or this very day but certainly it
we're better off now than we were 100
years ago or 200 years ago there are
always ups and downs so it's uh it's
always dangerous to say this today this
very day is the best day in history
probably isn't we've got an invasion in
uh Ukraine that's turning back the clock
we're still not over the effects of
covet but you know on average looking at
the overall trend yeah we're better off
than we were 50 years ago or 100 years
ago or 200 years ago and a thousand
years ago a lot of young people uh
suffer from anxiety far more than has
ever been recorded before and I I
believe one of the reasons is the
constant dopamine exposure they get to
negative imagery whether it's the war in
Ukraine the pandemic whatever it may be
that this sensory overload has created
an atmosphere in there in their heads
that things have never been worse than
they are now what's the best way to
realign young impressionable Minds about
why in your estimation the trend is
pretty good
yeah it's you know it's not just the the
dopamine hit of the image every 20
seconds it's also the overall message a
lot of young people are being told that
the species is going to go extinct if
not from
climate change than from artificial
intelligence or uh or or Civil War uh so
I think the news just has to put things
in perspective because the journalism is
a non-random sample of the worst things
happening everywhere on on Earth that's
kind of what news is uh the slow trends
that creep up a few percentage points a
year like the reduction of extreme
poverty increased access to electricity
and clean water uh Rising literacy
declining child mortality declining
maternal mortality all of these are
never never burst on the scene on
Thursday and so you never see a headline
but they transform the world because
these changes uh compound also there are
things that good things that consist of
things that don't happen like just a few
years ago we were obsessed with
terrorism it felt like there was
constantly a terrorist attack now uh
they are uh uh far less frequent but you
never see a headline it's been several
years since a European city has uh shot
up or or blown up by terrorists so the
news gives a non-random sample of the uh
generally of what's going wrong and so
more of a focus on long-term trends on
putting particular events in statistical
context so that a school shooting or a
police shooting doesn't mean that you
are in danger if you uh step out onto
the pavement just so that people could
put the anecdotes and images in context
of which way the world was going also
when it comes to to things that are
creeping up on us like climate change
um some perspective as to uh what is
again what is what is going right what
are the changing estimates of the
probabilities of the different scenarios
a lot of young people can't get out of
our head their heads the worst case
scenario which seemed disconcertingly
too likely a few years ago and now the
estimates are that the worst case
scenario is is much less likely that's
the kind of news that needs to be
highlighted and the people who are
counseling young people I I have seen
this even at my own institution uh
dealing with say climate anxiety they
say well yes it's such a serious problem
that is very good that you're anxious
well no your anxiety is not going to
save the planet your actions are going
to save the planet if you develop clean
meat or clean energy or better policies
but simply being miserable is not going
to help the planet and unfortunately a
lot of our counselors are conveying
exactly the wrong message well funny
enough there was a report only last week
about uh actually the the incidence of
depression and anxiety amongst young
people and it established really quite
clearly that if you could distract those
people by making them think about
positive things or other stuff than the
stuff the negative things they were
dwelling on actually it had a a
self-fulfilling prophecy they ended up
feeling more positive and less depressed
I I don't doubt it and it the the
reaction you get to that kind of
suggestion is well the world is burning
and uh things are getting worse you
don't want to instill complacency you
don't want people to think oh everything
is great I can lie back and relax well
of course that isn't the message the
message is things get better only if you
make them better but you've got to have
the confidence that trying to make the
world a better place might now get now
and again work and the message that
we've been sending is nothing is working
despite ever everyone's efforts to make
the world a better place things are
getting worse and worse until the
species goes extinct
and so the message can't just be let's
distract ourselves with you know with
with kittens and and heartwarming
stories of you know policemen who buys
groceries for a welfare mom if that
that's not what constructive journalism
would consist of it would consist of uh
the growth of Renewables the new
technologies on the horizon that might
deliver abundant clean energy the uh of
the countries that have eliminated
diseases the new vaccines for diseases
like malaria and and
other diseases the uh Rising literacy
rates be decline of coal uh there's lots
of actually substantive positive
developments that are simply not
reported except for a handful of sites
that specialize in it that I think more
people should subscribe to for their
mental health and for no other reason
but also to involve the the
countering the danger of complacency is
the danger of fatalism doesn't matter
what we do but what's going to help me
as well enjoy
yeah I totally agree
um one of the other scourges of modern
life other than this constant obsession
with all things negative is the attack
on Free Speech you went to Harvard
University and it was just ranked the
worst school for free speech in the
United States by the foundation of
individual rights and expression they
got zero points out of a hundred how do
you feel is it a Harvard alumni that it
is effectively become a walking talking
enemy of free speech
yes well I'm not
I'm not an undergraduate alumnus but I
am a professor so I'm I'm right there
think of things and together with some
colleagues we have formed the Council on
academic freedom at Harvard in order to
push back and in fact those rankings
were even a little bit convenient
because when we met with the president
last week and when we're meeting with
the dean tomorrow first thing we're
gonna uh do it uh the first that we did
was to say hey we came in in last place
in 248 universities don't you think we
should do something about this uh and I
hope we will why why are University
campuses All Over America and it's
happening in the UK why are they not
embracing
Free Speech why are they so insistent on
trying to suppress people's views D
platform people's views they don't like
have we got to this place
I would almost split the question free
speech is a deeply weird concept as far
as the human mind is concerned it's very
unintuitive what's obvious is that
people who disagree with me are
spreading dangerous falsehoods and must
be suppressed for the greater good
that's just a natural way we think the
idea of free speech going back to a
little bit the ancient Greeks and John
Stuart Mill and the Free Speech movement
that constantly has to be renewed people
need to be reminded of why they should
ignore their instincts to suppress
voices they disagree with step back and
realize hey it feels like I'm right but
you know I'm not infallible I'm not
omniscient a lot of people in the past
thought they were right they turned out
to be wrong a better system is one where
everyone gets to voice their opinions
and we get to uh argue about who's right
who's wrong well I do think uh Professor
Pink as long as people like you are
still at Harvard there's a hope there's
a tiny fragment of Hope for them when it
comes to defending Free Speech
it's great to have you on the programs
I wish you luck and getting them all on
side it's great to have you on Facebook
and I said so thank you so much indeed
for joining me
fascinating guy i writes tremendous
books uncensored next one of bravaman
says that anti-gay or anti-female
discrimination is not enough to qualify
you for claiming Asylum has she
forgotten her Humanity it was just a
kind of tough talk that will secure our
borders we'll debate that next
[Music]
thank you
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
thank you
coming up on the talks to Ella bravaman
rips up the rule book in a blistering
attack on International Asylum laws
branding them unfit for the modern age
plus sick note Britain sees the average
worker take almost eight days off in a
year that's the highest level since 2008
and its last orders for the phrase same
again as publicans are told to ditch the
expression in their bin Crackdown on
binge drinking
[Music]
welcome back to players Welcome Center
I'm joined by my patney political
journalist Avis and Tina told TV's all
around Adrian and the podcaster Ella
wheeler welcome to all of it hello
welcome we've seen these two obviously
many times but nice to see you here um
just want to play a clip this is from
last night so nothing to do with you
guys but it's quite funny this was the
fascinating debate I was having with
this chess champion or wannabe champion
who beat the world champion and there
was this allegation that he had used
anal beads uh and this is what he said
have you ever used anal beads while
playing chess
not a question I ever thought I'd ask a
guest to be honest but uh well you know
your curiosity is a bit concerning you
know maybe you're personally interested
but uh I can tell you no
okay categoric no of course yes
categorically I honestly I didn't I
didn't make the allegations I'm just
repeating what was put to you at the
time
well aside from having to explain what
anal beads are to a lot of people
following that clip uh Elon Musk decided
to get involved in a laughing emoji to
that clip when we put it up and then he
added frankly if you did just let him
win which is just quite funny and he has
a point if you're gonna go that far you
probably deserve it uh anyway it was
fascinating let's turn to swella
bravaman though because it's one of
bravaman has come out with some pretty
uh well typical Braverman thoughts about
Asylum this is what she said about gay
and female people
are we gonna listen to there are vast
ways of the world where it is extremely
difficult to be gay or to be a woman
where individuals are being persecuted
it is right that we offer sanctuary
but we will not be able to sustain an
asylum system if in effect simply being
gay or a woman or fearful of
discrimination in your country of origin
is sufficient to qualify for protection
right okay Ella
your reaction to that well I disagree
with Serena Braverman in terms of my
approach to immigration policy is much
more liberal but I think the point that
she raises in terms of this sort of
stumbling block that we seem to be
coming up against democratically and
about how a government can enact
immigration policy what kind of
decisions can be made and this sort of
perennial issue of the European
convention and human rights which you
know is basically talking about I think
has is a debate that has to be had out
you know whether or not she's right of
course there are lots of places where
well she used the term vast suedes which
would suggest that she's you know still
intends the the kind of generosity of
the Asylum process to be quite vast
um and you would hope so but obviously
there are you know there are practical
questions around whether or not the
simple kind of tick box technicalities
of signing up to the echr
um is relevant anymore whether that's
something that this country wants to do
and I think at least we should have that
debate I mean Paula every time she opens
a mouthful of breviment half the country
screams you're racist you're the issue
of that I mean she gets a hell of a lot
of abuse other people commend her
straight talking and the fact she's
prepared to sometimes say the unmanned
questionable and not cares about
upsetting people to encourage debate
whether you sit with this particular one
I mean there are going to be millions
and millions more people seeking Asylum
we know they're seeking to be refugees
no but there are we know that no peers
no we don't yes we do no we don't we
know that there are people guessing that
that is what it is highly likely as a
result no climate change if nothing else
it is highly likely we're going to see
it go where are they going to go we know
because the figures tell us that most
refugees go to the country next door
that is where most something like
two-thirds that's where they go that
wasn't what I said well so there's going
to be a lot more people coming to
claiming Asylum okay
in the UK well all over the all over the
world that may be the case if the
numbers are going to go exponentially
very high which seems likely most
experts believe that is it not sensible
of a British Home Secretary to say well
maybe we should look at trimming the
criteria making it more concentrated on
particular groups of people this isn't
about the criteria peers it's very
simple the criteria says are you
suffering persecution that's what it's
about it's the home office it's the
infrastructure it's the system that is
failing and that is under the watch of
swella bravna that's what needs to be
looked at so we don't Point our finger
at the 20 000 odd people who've made
their way across the channel we point
our finger at swella Braven and we ask
her why is it that the home office is no
longer fit for her well we can also
point a finger at the Smugglers who are
making tons of money from making men
women and children and don't care if
they drown on so why do we not then have
a center in Calais where we can properly
process we should but that's not that's
a different kind of part of this debate
are you I mean
she's got to do a tricky job sort of
breath right we we many people believe
this country has not currently got
control of its borders there are tens of
thousands of people coming here
illegally on these boats and so on and
so on other countries reporting similar
stuff this specific point she's making
are we now in an age where a lot of
people claim to be persecuted who are
not actually by the old definition being
persecuted
um I don't really know where she would
have got that from because I mean my
judgment would be that she actually
doesn't really know at all what's going
on with the figures but you said just
now that she's very straight talking I
would actually argue she was the master
of deflection she gave that huge speech
today which I think is just a right-wing
dog whistle to the right wing side of
her party the white nationalists who are
in the conservative party and there's no
policy there no idea what we're going to
do yet do next no proposition she's just
she's just a racist is she a racist she
is a racist because what she's doing is
she's hedging her bet she's going to
become party leader hopefully in her
mind in the next 10 sorry five years and
she's whistling to that side of the
party that might not have elected Wishy
sunak because they are also racist but
isn't it true that absolutely anyone in
this country who raises any concern
about even the small boats coming in
such large numbers immediately gets
called to races in the same way that
anyone who raises a red flag about any
element of gender ideology gets called
transfer because I would say that's a
lazy whistle the other ways hang out
these Chinese slurs against people and
actually often it's just a wild
exaggeration of what they're attempting
to do which is having a debate about the
best way to handle things but then if
that was true why did she then identify
being homosexual and why did she
identify being a woman why didn't she
say for example seek an asylum as a
political because you're a political
activist why don't you say that she has
specific specifically identified topics
that she knows are going to get people
riled up she wants us to fight with each
other because then that means I would
say I would say people are riled up
anyway so I'm not sure they need much
riling people do genuinely care about
this stuff let's move on to something
else like people care about Ella does
working from home make you fat this is
this new survey uh because so many more
people are now sitting at home
apparently they're all couch potatoes I
work from home and obviously you can see
I mean clearly disprove the theory but
what do you think of this idea that
we're now becoming a nation of lazy
couch potatoes and it's being
exemplified by the work from home
phenomenal everything it's a bit like
everything kills you everything makes
you fat these days when we are we I
think we're unhealthily obsessed with
being obsessed with our weight and but
so it's obvious that if you're not out
in the world then it's going to have an
effect and I don't think we should be at
all in the business of lecturing people
about their lifestyle choices when it
comes to weight or anything else but I
do I don't agree I think the nanny
should we should have a nanny State and
we do it all the time we did it with
cigarettes we do it with the stuff that
makes sense it's awful why shouldn't we
need it with cigarettes but the thing
about working from home it's not that
it's bad for your waistline it's I think
it's bad for you know public life I
think we should be making actually a
positive argument against working from
home in fact okay well you've all made
the effort to come in today Ava where do
you sit on this I mean I think working
from home has benefits but it also
clearly has negative one of them might
well be you don't move as much
apparently it's statistically proven you
don't do your steps that you should do I
don't know I think you sleep a lot
better if you're at home you've got more
time with your kids I think you've got
an all-round healthier life and I do
think a lot of this policy comes out of
the sort of sorry but the big
corporations who'd like you to travel
into work and buy from their sandwich
shops and pay money on the train well
it's a bit of that and I do feel for the
small businesses who post pandemic just
have lost all their business because of
traffic you know foot traffic but I also
think that office life does form a far
more creative entity for many companies
particularly creative companies then the
work from home phenomena it does does
call it when we're all together if we're
all in a room together now we would be
more creative as a group and if we're
all at home and and that's why we're
moving to this hybrid
kind of format aren't we when that
research was done that research was done
in 2021 and of course we're all kind of
sluggish not really knowing where we
were and yes our backs ached because we
sat in uncomfortable chairs now we're
moving into this hybrid stage we know
what it's about do you know the market
for fitness apps is quoted as being a
hundred and twenty billion pounds and
you know what I do I I get on my Peloton
exactly and I watch the I watch talk TV
exactly you're a Peloton man absolutely
specifically an Olivia Amato man really
okay best trainer uh thank you Pat great
to see you there's something I want to
say before you go early for five seconds
you know it wouldn't you rather be out
in the pressure than on a Palestine I
would I'm gonna go the fresh air right
now that's not for me I thank you pack
whatever you're up to Keep It Uncensored
good night
[Music]
thank you
good evening I'm Piers Morgan uncensored
in New York City King peers and King Q I
think it's only one for one king
he's mopped your weight Trump yeah look
at him fail stop working just cause
their skin folk don't mean they're
kinfolks do you believe you can win this
war but he's making me cry again they're
trying to force you out yes I feel
betrayed keep it award-winning
Lucy Letty will die behind bars and a
senior Doctor Who first raised concerns
about that he wants NHS managers to be
regulated we needed answers a lot sooner
this is what seven years down the line I
mean it's completely ludicrous we need
accountability we need performance in
all walks of life if this nurse had
misgendered somebody on a ward she'd
have been out the door when they first
got together there were press stories
way TK team that would make her a better
princess of wealth Elaine Maxwell agreed
to be interviewed for the very first
time I obviously wish I'd never met him
Donald Trump has just said he expects to
be arrested at 7 30 P.M
the concelli party can certainly win the
next election yes
did you say yes I have taken drugs and
they bent the rules or lied on the visa
application form and therefore got it
there needs to be an intervention around
abortion laws Parliament is Sovereign
Parliament can determine these things
the rest of the world has watched on in
sort of mounting horror as this story
has unraveled for you it was incredibly
personal the death toll from the Titanic
tragedy has risen to 1522 and may God
rest your souls
foreign
[Music]